What is some of the strategies to do this,
uh,
modify or actually break a mechanism of action that would lead to toxicity.
So when you know,
the,
the mechanism of,
of what has to happen in the body in order to cause a toxic effect,
you,
um,
you make that greatly disfavored through,
through molecular design or you make an impossible,
um,
change the,
the various reactive functional groups that you know are related to that
toxicity.
You reduced or eliminated bioavailability.
We've talked about a lot.
Um,
you reduce the need for associated,
uh,
hazardous substances.
What do I mean by that?
Well,
we'll talk more about it,
but sometimes the molecule that you're using isn't what you're most worried
about.
However,
it requires the use of another associated substance.
One example might be paint.
Maybe you've made the perfectly innocuous die and that's fantastic,
but that di can only be used in a particular paint solvent system and that
solvent system is as bad.
What you've,
what you've done is you've shifted your hazard concern from a that molecule to
the fact that it requires a different,
uh,
toxic substance.
And we talked a lot last session about the design,
uh,
of,
end of useful life phonic life.
So we are,
the mechanism of action is known.
The,
the first one,
uh,
it's possible to,
um,
to design the molecule so that electronically it can't carry out those
reactions.
And in order to bring about toxicity,
it is just not able to react.
Um,
and that is,
um,
that's always going to result in lower toxicity with the reactive functional
groups.
There are whole classes of,
uh,
of different chemicals that we know bring about toxicity.
Uh,
we know that certain types of electro files,
those electron loving,
um,
molecules are going to carry out reactions in the body.
If you make something less electrophilic,
if you move that electrophilic group,
you're going to drastically does favor the ability for that to do it.
So changing the reactive functional group,
a,
um,
a night trial,
that's a c triple bond and,
uh,
nay trials are widely used in industry,
are being any groups
widely used in industry for wide range of,
you'll note that it might wind up being able to release cyanide
by moving away from,
uh,
the use of an eight trial group substituting in another group,
you'll be able to move to a less toxic alternatives.
Uh,
we've talked a lot about reducing or eliminating bioavailability since we know
how to design molecules that have a different log kows [inaudible] partition
coefficient that we all remember,
uh,
whether or not something's going to be respirable and be able to breathe in by
changing that,
we can get out of the zone of,
uh,
of bioavailability.
And I already mentioned that different types of,
uh,
using the example of paints that it requires solvents,
different types of plastics that require particular types of additives that we
have already visited.
There can be a carcinogenic sometimes,
uh,
endocrine disrupting,
moving away from,
from those substances requiring these or these other hazardous substances.
And then we covered a lot of ground last,
uh,
last week,
on the end of useful life.